BMW has given its c6 50 GT and c6 50
sport a facelift the changes in the sea
650 sport are largely limited to the
design new lights at the front and the
slim figure aimed to give the maxi
scooter
well sporty-er look the c6 50 GT now
comes with a new safety feature it's
already familiar to the car sector but
its introduction to the two wheeler
world sees BMW breaking new ground
Benzema Tatas reporter off knows from
experience that motorbike or scooter
riders bend forward when turning this is
in order to try to compensate for the
blind spot in response BMW decided to
give one of the two scooters a new side
view assist Ralph wants to find out
whether this is just a gimmick or
whether it makes sense and might soon be
seen in motorbikes - took a knee Atticus
gimmick oh this is absolute sinful
incredible general mood for a Hong Kong
at speeds of between 25 and 80 km/h
beside us sister SVA and forms the
writer of any other vehicles within a 5
meter vicinity system then flashes up a
warning triangle on the MIR stock of the
c6 50 GT
upon the mobility the feature is ideal
for urban conditions as BMW motorbikes
executive Michele hime hot
you have frequent Lane changing and high
traffic density which is where the
feature can help prevent accidents the
built in sensors and a control module
are in the right positions as is the
warning triangle and the stock of the
mirror Trigon something in the GT which
Ralph took for a ride
packs a two cylinder in-line engine with
44 kilowatts
it makes the sprint from 0 to 100 km/h
in seven and a half seconds abs and
automatic stability control our standard
fitted Ramon similarites Ralph urges
motorbike riders who scoff at larger
scooters like this new BMW c6 50 GT to
try one first yes there are features
that really are taboo body footprints
and hide Gribbs heated seat and the
continuously variable automatic
transmission are not normally associated
with motorbike riding but this scooter
offers plenty of comfort great wind
protection and really packs a punch a
two-cylinder engine tilted forward by 70
degrees has a far better response which
Ralph really appreciates in city traffic
the suspension is more sensitive and in
general you really notice the technical
advances this is more than just a visual
facelift on katika in the tub the design
of the c6 50 GT has seen only minor
modifications compared to the preceding
model there is a new rear lamp cluster
for example on the practical side an
adjustable windshield powered by a
handlebar mounted switch also new is the
automatic daytime riding light in this
mode if the bike registers light
conditions falling below a certain level
it will automatically switch from
daytime to low B
what the Meeks hidden body riding around
on the streets of Valencia has given
Ralph a chance to check out the main new
feature
besides you assists it's basically a
blind spot alert which many people say
is too much for a two-wheeler but ralph
was glad to have it on board it's no
replacement for looking over your
shoulder of course but it really does
boost safety when you need to switch
lanes fast in city traffic Ralph could
well imagine this being introduced for
motorbike soon as well now when
distinguished band Optus Biden matura
and Corvette